well we love seeing you in front of the
camera you're getting quite a glowing
reputation as a director what was the
most challenging aspect of first going
behind the monitors oh
trying to make the schedule of the
amount of screwing around that the cast
on next gen including me is famous for
laughing between tanks taking the piss
out of each other constantly because you
know the Star Trek was serious and power
strike was generally very so when when
we were when we cut
who was wrestling that was singing there
was all kinds of [__] Patrick and dwarf
Dorne used to wrestle what and Brett
would do to uh like you were on Vegas
and he'd do a pretend Mike court and and
we were so bad that um especially in the
third fourth or fifth season
the only time we would shut up was not
um
roll sound have speed camera no we're
still yeah you have to yell
action
number one
we we went right up until the end of
action and it drove [__] director's
crazy and then when I was direct I
thought I get it and also early on you
have to prove yourself yeah I had a data
show so I had Brent spider was the he
was the lead for the weekend he's very
reliable
uh Renee shiveria wrote the episode as a
spec script who's now a big show runner
from also from Castle and um I'd been
shadowing for almost three years right
so I was really you were I thought I was
ready